the natsunatu sequence of the movie
Global like it was famous before the
movie even came out because I think it
was like released on YouTube and people
started going the song was released
people went nuts over it
[Music]
do you remember the moment of being like
wow this is crossing all of these Global
boundaries people are really loving it
yeah absolutely I feel it's it's no more
our song it's no more rr's uh song it's
it's become the public song different
age groups different culture people they
just embraced it I don't know if they
even understand the lyrics of it but I
think the beat is so thumping and it's
so foot tapping and they just started to
embrace this uh all over the world from
Japan to us I don't know what's
happening I'm I'm like a third person
observing like what's happening did we
even think about this when we were
choreographing the whole song wow I
think it's such a Serial moment I just
can't ask for anything more how long did
it take to rehearse that scene before
you shot it I think we rehearsed for
seven days we rehearsed in Ukraine in
front of the president's Palace who was
So Graceful to agree to for the shoot to
happen there because he was an actor
himself before he was a president and
seven days with 150 dancers professional
fantastic dances and an amazing crew of
another 200 people the whole song took
about 17 days to shoot my knees still
wobble when I think about it I think I
lost about four kilos there's the
sequence where you guys are doing the
suspenders and like going down and I
want to learn how to do it so bad yes
what's the tips how do I do it how yeah
rehearse and uh 17 retakes okay you'll
get it I mean SS Raja Mali was going
frame by frame to make sure that you
guys were insane yeah I mean I can be at
35 degrees my co-star will be at 45
degrees and he'll be like no you either
matched him or he matches you so it was
he was very very particular and we used
to wonder why is he being so anal about
it why is he being super cool it's
fantastic but today I think all that
torture the beautiful torture led us to
this and sitting with you I think I
think it's worth it what would you like
to see in a sequel and what haven't you
done
working with Mr rajmali I tend to switch
my brain off because he's so good at
what he does and I really can't imagine
what goes on in his mind because it'll
always beat you and how he does it I
just don't know
are you ready for Sunday Oscar's week I
don't know if I'll ever be ready for
Oscars I mean so nervous I'm so excited
I don't know if I'm going to walk that
carpet as an actor or just as a fanboy I
mean everybody kind of fans out when
they're there who are you excited to see
everybody I grew up watching I can't
name this so many people and especially
I think Kate Blanchard is one of my top
of my list and Tom Cruise who I've been
growing up watching from Top Gun to now
man he's incredible I've heard you want
to work with him I want to walk with him
under his production whatever let him
direct me I don't know yeah I just want
to be Associated I think he's such an
inspiring man I mean he looks the same
nothing changes about him you know it's
weird Ryan so the movie is so much more
than the accolades I think that it's
it's getting but I'm just curious
because the movie is nominated for best
original song yeah I personally feel it
should have gotten more love this award
season do you agree how do you feel
about that do you I don't know I think
we've got enough from people's love and
appreciation for this art and this film
and everything from here is just another
feather on the hand it's just everything
is extra right now and we are already
very happy we are satisfied as actors
and everything from here is just just
not a book and we're just enjoying the
moment just to be here and it is so
overwhelming that the mecca of films
that is La the Hollywood and they were
so warm I think a good cinema doesn't
have a language and uh RR is an example
for that and I'm so proud and I'm so
happy that my director uh you know made
me part of such a movement and such a
film and I'll always keep it in my heart
and I want to be part of such films I
feel like when I was watching you in
this movie I was like this guy could do
any franchise he wanted he could be you
know Marvel movie A Star Wars movie et
cetera et cetera is there any franchise
that you are particularly interested in
put it out there I want to be in every
franchise where people are really
watching and buying that ticket I want
to be in every film in every country
where people appreciate art in the films
and uh Cinema basically it's the cinema
is becoming a global Cinema it's no more
Hollywood Bollywood it's burning all the
woods and becoming a global cinnamon I'm
I'm so fortunate to be part of that I
much that could be around be brought to
like SS
Rogers I think we are going to host you
a big buddy if that happens okay
really she is one of the first people to
say and I'm fingers crossed I really
hope that happens
I mean at least for my director are
there any directors that will be there
on Sunday that you would love to work
with oh God a lot of them I want to work
with Mr JJ Abraham Clinton Tarantino is
my all time I grew up watching so much
of those films oh my God big influence
and Inglorious bastard is always on my
playlist uh on a Sunday
yes of course somebody who challenges me
and all these directors I think they
challenge their actors and make it so
interesting so you are a highly
decorated actor one of the best in your
craft how does it feel to add Academy
Award nominee to your list of accolades
well I mean the reason we are all here
is thanks to the original song we just
nominated and my music director who's
done 27 years of work 250 films and it's
long due he gets this credit and I'm so
happy for my music composer mm kiravani
we're all just here as a family as a
support system for the film though we
are not nominated but I just feel like
we're just there for him and we're all
and thanks to my director it was just
made it possible for all of us to walk
that red carpet in a personal note you
are going to your dad soon
yes how are you feeling about that
excited Long View I've been waiting for
10 years I've been married for 10 years
I think we've found time everything is
good so far
[Music]
foreign
thank you